nous allons mener une opération à Tchernihiv
salut des personnes salut des malades salut
blessés
Vous qui devez maintenant être emmené à Kiev
pour une aide supplémentaire
nous avons en fait formé ce voyage après
en tant que volontaires là-bas Vyacheslav
Zaporozhets, ils ont organisé un groupe de yak
a sorti des gens qui venaient des villes environnantes
besoin de soins urgents là-bas
quelque part, quelque chose d'autre s'est encore interrompu
Ma mère a été hospitalisée car
à côté de notre notre appartement à
Une puissante bombe a explosé à Tchernihiv
au début, elle dit une vague si chaude
qui l'a rejetée et puis la deuxième vague
est venu et a complètement démoli son plafond là-bas
éclat d'obus et maman s'est retrouvée à l'hôpital
mais elle a eu une opération des yeux là-bas
il a fallu faire une autre opération
déjà ils ne pouvaient pas faire et celui-ci est entouré
bombardé et ainsi de suite Et j'ai déjà appelé
au médecin-chef et là je dis allons-y
Je dis sortons-le d'une manière ou d'une autre
faisons la première chose, nous allons chercher avec des drones
il n'y avait pas de drogue d'aucune sorte ou pas du tout
des forces armées de la Fédération de Russie
voulait explorer ces endroits où il y a danger
parce qu'il y a des champs où A est entouré de forêt et
ils ajustent les drones et le char s'éteint
Bach a couvert le terrain et est revenu et c'est tout
Le fait est que Vyacheslav, un volontaire, oui, il a dit que
il y a des choses dangereuses ces choses doivent
nous sommes allés à Tchernihiv pour jeter un coup d'œil
après tout, cela signifie qu'il a été enlevé
des personnes gravement malades y étaient emmenées par une grand-mère déjà
là avec un problème de jambe, ça veut dire qu'ils l'ont enlevé
seuls ceux assis pouvaient parce que seulement deux
la voiture est arrivée, il a fallu revenir
Ils ont donc été emmenés de l'hôpital régional à
la boucle est normale ou plus forte
regarde vraiment un peu plus
tout est bon tout
Bonne chance à toi
nous sommes partis et ils ont continué.
nous avons vu un itinéraire sûr et ils
puis ils ont continué à sortir ce qui était ici dans
certaines voitures avaient chacune un marcheur, puis
ils ont quitté la caravane de Kulikivka maintenant
c'est déjà sûr, mais ça allait
un peu quoi
très important quand l'humanitaire est prévu
la mission est de comprendre où il se trouve
un adversaire avec qui vous étiez d'accord ou non
d'accord parce que nous voyons que la Russie n'est pas
remplit les obligations qu'il assume
lui-même et pour les civils sans dire
déjà là pour l'armée là-bas sur la résiliation
de feu C'est-à-dire qu'il ne s'agit de rien et c'est pourquoi lorsque vous
vous êtes d'accord avec un tel
un adversaire, un ennemi en tout genre
remplit les obligations assumées par
assurer un passage en toute sécurité
la population civile en a besoin
contrôler contrôler ce qu'il peut
Pour ce faire, un drone peut aider
d'un type différent s'il n'y a pas une telle possibilité
il faut neutraliser les déchets
pour enregistrer que là je suis un danger si ça va
un couloir civil, et ça doit être bruyant
si convenu ou tacitement
maintenir ce couloir et
Contrôlez ces endroits, Dieu nous en préserve
il y a un danger pour que nous puissions rapidement
Penchez-vous en avant et voyez ce danger
Je pense que ça va permettre de sauver des vies
qui marchent dans ce couloir convenu
ou pas d'accord, alors encore ça
plus important mais d'utiliser ces
les drones doivent comprendre que nous pouvons les
perdre et reconstituer ces Drones sur
la production de ces Drones pour l'achat de ces
Les drones nécessitent des fonds constants car
le parc a besoin d'être renouvelé, les pertes se poursuivent
pannes
quelques erreurs et ainsi de suite. C'est pourquoi
nécessaire pour préserver la vie d'un civil
la population et les militaires sans équivoque
Les Russes utilisent assez bien les drones
utiliser des drones, c'est-à-dire le donner
bon est nécessaire pas pas au début
vous n'avez pas besoin de vous lancer dans le casting
pour que là ils soient chair à canon et ainsi de suite
alors c'est vraiment mais ceux qui
est engagé et je sais en Biélorussie
l'information est tout ce qu'ils ont maintenant
quant aux Drones, ils sont très forts
sont financés et donc les drones sont très importants
important pour sauver la vie des soldats et
population civile
[musique]
J'en appelle à tous ceux qui s'en soucient
soutenir l'approvisionnement et la production
Drones civils et militaires pour
détails qui seront précisés à la fin
vidéo ou dans les commentaires après la vidéo
merci